Social networking sites are used by 1/3 people around the world
They have had a great impact on society
But what about our bodies?
Here are 5 ways of social networking and the Internet
Influence your mind at the moment
Can not you stop?
It is surprising that 5-10% of Internet users
Are not actually able to control the amount of time they spend online.
Although it is self-addiction and not drug addiction,
Examine the brains of these people
Revealed weakness in areas similar to those of drug addicts.
Specifically, there is a clear decline of white matter in
Areas that control emotions, attention and decision making.
Because social media provide immediate rewards for little effort,
Your mind begins to re-install itself, so you want these stimuli,
As you begin to want more of these neurological excitements after each reaction.
Looks like drugs. Is not it?
We also see a change when we look at multitasking.
You may think that those who use social media
Or permanently switch between work and websites
They are best at multitasking,
But studies revealed that when compared to those who use the means of communication frequently to others,
Their performance is much worse during task switching tests.
Increasing online multitasking reduces your brain's ability to filter out overlaps,
It can even make it harder for your mind to learn information in a way that you can remember
Like your phone rings in the middle of a product.
Or wait .. Is it really Ren ??
Phantom Vibration Syndrome is a relatively new psychological phenomenon
Where you think you felt your phone was shaking, while it did not vibrate.
In a study, 89% of those who underwent it said
They face this at least once every two weeks.
It seems that our minds now explain any accentuation as a real vibration of our phones.
As far as the madness of the subject seems,
The technique began to re-install our nervous system
Our minds have become more exciting than they were before
Social media also stimulate the secretion of dopamine-
A chemical that gives a feeling of improvement.
Using MRI, scientists have found that
The reward center in people's minds is much more active when they talk about their own opinions,
Unlike when they listen to others.
Not surprisingly - we all like to talk about ourselves, right?
But it turns out that while 30-40% of the talks are face-to-face
Including talking about our own experiences,
80% of communication through social networking sites
Are just about ourselves.
The same parts of your mind regarding sexual prominence, motivation and love
They are stimulated through your use of social-
And even more when you learn that you audience.
Our bodies physiologically reward us to talk about ourselves online!
But it's not all about ourselves.
In fact, studies on relationships have found that
Partners tend to be more impressive when they first meet online
Rather than face to face.
Whether it is because people are more unknown or perhaps because they are more clear about their future goals,
There is a statistical increase in the success of relationships that begin over the Internet.
Thus, while the Internet has changed our oral communication with increasing physical distances,
Perhaps the most important people ended up being even closer.
By talking about social media,
We've made you ask us questions on Twitter, Instagram, Facebook, Templer, Google +
All the social networks that we have found,
We made "Q & A" videos on! AsapTHOUGHT
So if you want to be more familiar with AsapSCIENCE and behind the scenes
Try it using the link in the description!
Have a question that makes you want an answer?
Ask him in comments or on Facebook and Twitter
Finally we also have a mailbox for all the amazing science lovers
Who have asked to send mail or other things over the years.
We will love to hear from you all!
So feel comfortable using the title on the screen or in the description box.
Subscribe to more weekly science videos!